my name is steve haraguchi and i'm the
director of ai programs here
we launched this program about two years
ago and so we'll be talking a little bit
about the ai program
what it entails uh what classes we offer
but the feature of today's webinar is
really to showcase some projects that
happen in a specific course of ours
which is one of our favorite and most
fun courses natural language
understanding which is led by professor
chris potts
so before we dive in and i introduce the
speakers um a little bit about our
program this program was created in
september 2019 so we're coming up on
uh what is that
three coming up on three years
and the idea of this program was a
little bit different from a lot of
professional education or a lot of
online education that previously existed
in that all of these professional
courses are directly based off of
graduate level courses at stanford and
so we do use the lectures and many of
the same lecture videos and content from
the graduate level courses at stanford
and then we mix we create a mix of
programming assignments and written
assignments that are also taken from the
graduate courses to give what we believe
to be a very high level very rigorous
and very intensive
professional education program
and we make some slight differences and
adjustments to the course material just
to give working professionals a little
bit of added flexibility
uh both in the way that they schedule
and and choose to take the courses as
well as a little bit of flexibility in
terms of how they go about completing
the assignments uh knowing that all
working you know working professionals
are likely to have very busy schedules
family schedules and so we try to build
in a little bit of flexibility
into how you can go about completing the
courses
i'm going to talk a lot about the
details uh at the end of this
presentation we'll have a sort of q a
open q a about the program itself but
really just quickly at present our
program offers six courses
um covering the base you know
foundational ai techniques
um to foundational uh approaches to
machine learning but really diving under
the hood a lot of a lot of algorithms
that you
likely have used or or may be learning
about elsewhere
as well as electives we like to think of
more elective courses with two options
around natural language processing and
understanding
we've recently added a reinforcement
learning course as well as a machine
learning with graphs course
the target audience for this program is
practicing scientists and engineers
who are seeking a very in-depth sort of
foundational
knowledge of ai so most of our classes
are actually not using common packages
for a lot of machine learning approaches
you're actually developing them from
scratch
uh with the rationale on the approach
being by really understanding what goes
under the hood of a lot of modern
approaches uh it puts you in the best
position to deeply understand what's
happening
uh to put them into practice
to
um to uh
apply them to your work as well as
potentially to invent new approaches uh
in your future
so um with that though
today's main feature
is to hear from two learners who
completed the program so they actually
can speak to their experience
completing
three classes to complete the
professional certificate
but will feature their experience in one
of our classes which is natural language
understanding
so um our two students are navdeep and
annika navdeep will be first the natural
language understanding class uh is
actually next offered uh beginning in
about two weeks january 24th all the
classes are ten weeks
and you can see the topics here that
this course focuses on
it takes a broad view
of many different natural language
understanding approaches as it relates
to
word representations
natural language inference you can see
all the topics here
um
modern sort of contextual word
representations as well as how to put
together
an nlu project so in addition to
assignments that take place in this
class there's also an open-ended project
uh that is a topic of your own choosing
you'll actually pick a topic related to
the course material that is most
interesting to you
find and select a data set
and put together a project and in this
class we have the option of um doing a
project in groups
or uh doing a project individually so
what we've decided to do here since this
is our next class that's starting is
again we've been invited nav deep and
annika
here to share a little bit about what
they did in this class they'll each have
about 10 minutes to share
what they did in the natural language
understanding class they'll talk a
little bit about their experience
in the course and potentially broadly in
the program and we'll have plenty of
time for questions and answers at the
end uh both about our prog program
generally as well as uh about their
projects and what they did and what they
learned and how they may be applying
what they learned
to their their work today so uh before
we i introduce navdeep who's our first
speaker i just want to really thank both
of them for making the time uh to
prepare a couple of slides uh for you
all to see today as well as for taking
the time to set aside the hour
to join this webinar and talk a little
bit about their experience in the
program
so with that as i mentioned we'll go
into more detail of the program at the
very end of this but without further ado
oh here's the one slide about the
projects they are open-ended uh and
they're free choice and they can you
actually can complete these projects on
a work topic so i'm actually not sure if
navd or annika created uh projects
related to their day-to-day work but
that is something uh that folks um that
folks are able to do so you can actually
do it within the context of your current
employment if you'd like
so without further ado i'll turn it over
to nav deep uh who'll share a little bit
about his project and uh we'll have time
for a couple questions about his project
at the end
of his presentation before we move on to
annika but then after that at the very
end we'll have plenty of time to talk
about the program so
deep if you can hear us uh feel free to
go live here with your camera and mike
and uh and start to share
sounds good thanks steve uh
and thanks for introducing uh hello
everyone so
i'm now deep chain and as mentioned this
was my paper customer sentiment analysis
using weak supervision for customer
agent chat
is something i worked as a part of
cs
xcs224u and i'll be sharing more details
about that as well as this was my third
course in ai professional certificate so
we'll give some overview
about it as well
so
a little bit about myself
i
am navdeep jain
i work as a lead research engineer in
applied ai research team at comcast
if you are not familiar with what
comcast or what type of company it is uh
it is us's largest internet and cable
provider company uh and we have multiple
verticals
for uh on which ai focuses so until
recently my focus had been on voice and
audio and most recently my role has
changed where i'll be more focused
towards chatbot
so
that is a bit about me
now
moving to this particular course so i
have two slides on xcs2 before you one
is like the key learning and then
second one is like focusing particularly
on the project that i worked on and how
i came up with the idea for that project
so
again you can find lots of details about
the course uh when you sign up when you
uh
when you you can find lots of details
just by looking at youtube videos as
well uh but here are a few things that i
think you press won't get just by
looking at videos
so the course
has three assignments
and
four
quizzes
uh one of the suggests i have key three
suggestions for this course
spend as much time as you can all these
three assignments which are mentioned
here word relatedness sentiment analysis
and pragmatic colored script description
uh
the last question in all three
assignments are build an original system
my recommendation is you spend as much
time as you can
making the base system trying to
try to win the competition so like for
all this assignment there is a back off
and it's a sort of competition so
always try to learn and try to apply
something original uh that would help
you to understand
all the key concepts which are being
used in nlp recently or even in the past
and i think these are the key whenever
you have when you have to come up with a
new idea if you have the better
understanding of
some of these key concepts that will
help you to progress better in the later
weeks
and again i think one thing to
understand this course is 10 weeks and
when you have to come up with an
original idea and write a paper it is
not a lot of time so that's why this
first three weeks becomes crucial that
you spend lots of time
understanding the key concept
uh
so that is one my second
my personal best like there are multiple
modules in the course
but for me the most useful was this
contextual representation
uh
this is the one like you many of you
might have heard about uh models like
bert
roberta but how they actually work under
the hood and then again how you can
practically use them modify them how you
can train a classifier using it or how
you can find unit all those things are
discussed in module 4 so i highly
recommend that if that is something you
are interested in
you focus
like particularly in this on this module
and
this is like a generic advice so
it's a 10 week of period and like uh
you know
get ready for some sort of adversity
like be it a personal life or whatever
so
for example i'll give you my example
so i live in philadelphia here on east
coast in us and while doing this course
i live close to schuylkill river
and we had a flooding in schuylkill
river it has never happened in eight
years and i was without like like i
needed to evacuate for five days and
things like that and then
my workstation basically macbook was not
working on one of the weekends so the
key takeaway there is all the
assignments mostly and on the sunday so
don't wait until saturday to finish your
course of course you have those five
days extension and you can exercise some
other
method to not uh
waste your time but i would suggest like
this is something for you to learn and
if you don't wait for the deadline this
will help you uh to better prepare for
the course
so those are like key idea about uh
pre-paper writing phase uh
now
in peop the paper writing phase is like
six weeks the first four weeks are
concepts quizzes and then the next phase
is paper writing uh and there are three
phases
uh the key thing here is uh you spend
enough like
good attention in each phase so that
it helps you for the next phase so if
you spend good amount of time
writing a better literature review you
can use
that portion of that review in your
final paper and it can help you
contribute to sex and call introduction
and related work so
the key thing is consider this as a
build up to the final paper and not as
an
independent entity so that will help you
uh to write a final paper again like
if you have never written a paper
then it is uh it is really
a learning experience because it can
take really long time
so uh
prepare for each phase well
so for literature review as i said if
you this is the phase where you read how
uh
other folks have worked on certain field
and how they have applied certain ai
concept and things like that and
and you have to summarize it the second
phase is experimental protocol now
always keep in mind you know
you may get over excited with the idea
of key learning but it's a 10 week
course so you have to
make sure that you
finish your part within 10 weeks an
experimental protocol is the phase
where
you have to have the full end-to-end
pipeline ready whereas you don't want to
use
all the data that you have but if you
don't you want to use all the gpu time
you have but you want to have your full
end-to-end system ready during this
experimental protocol phase so that uh
you have you are 100 sure that you can
deliver a final paper uh
after this phase so this is a key phase
where rather than spending all your time
building
a complete end-to-end system you build a
prototype during this and
also the writing over here will help you
to write data matrix and model section
in your final paper
and then the final paper so
key thing for final paper is i would say
spend some time learning latex
i don't know how if you are familiar
with it but it's it's a another language
to write a paper which is simpler
and it can be very useful once you know
it and if you are going to spend
if you aspire to become a researcher and
write lots of paper of course there is
some learning curve involved and i think
this
course is a good platform for you to get
started on that um
the
then moving to my particular paper and
how i came up with the idea so
my paper as i said was customer
sentiment analysis using weak
supervision for customer agent chat
um
as soon as i
and i have
made this paper public so you can find
it on uh on the portal that is
for
ai program but at the same time if you
go to this link you can read the paper
is publicly available
the key thing here is uh as soon as i
decided that i want to do this project
and luckily i i'm also part of applied
ai research team here and we have an
established nlp team so i reached out to
our
head of nlp research and uh
described about like i'm going to
participate in this program is there any
nlp
uh
problem that we have but none of other
researchers are focused on so that is
how the conversation started so even on
the first week i had access to some data
which was basically actual customer and
agent chat
that we have for comcast customer
service now we have this data and we
didn't have any label for it so the
question was what we can do
with this data and that is where it
helped i had some
sample data with me and then throughout
the course as i learned concept about
word relatedness as i learned concept
about sentiment analysis
and
i could relate to okay perhaps i can
apply this concept here perhaps i can
apply this concept here so the process
was like i would visit uh
i would have meeting with our director
of nlp every couple of weeks and bounce
back ideas with him and then by fourth
week i had some good understanding of
like what i want to do with the
data
and which could be useful for the
company and that is where like i think
steve manson this earlier uh
for me i got lucky it was feasible for
me to convert this project as as a work
project um so at comcast we have
something called lab week during which
you don't need to work on things you
work on your regular days and that is
what like this was my fall lab week uh
which helped me to involve other folks
as well
uh
for annotations and things like that
and then other thing is like once you
have some idea you always want to
bounce back with your mentors which
you'll have here
uh
in during the course and professor part
like he
holds office hours every thursday
throughout the course so this is the
only unique course where you have
opportunity to interact with the
professor himself
uh so you can bounce back the ideas with
him
and
can improve on it so my process was
working with professor pod working with
my cf and mentor at comcast so that the
idea is useful for comcast as well but
at the same time i can submit that as a
paper
and key contribution of this work uh
even though it may sound like uh
sentiment analysis is a solved problem
you will learn during the course that
the sentiment analysis mostly has been
applied to
customer reviews for
products on amazon for product on yelp
or it has been applied to twitter but it
has never been uh
because this is like not easy data to
get in public domain customer agent chat
so this was like sort of proprietary
data and there is no uh
large-scale
data or analysis available for this
particular domain so and then other
thing is you will realize that
this data is key but every concept that
we mostly use in ai currently requires
label data and
acquiring label data itself is a huge
challenge and that's where like we came
up with the idea that weak supervision
is something has been picking up in last
few years
and we focused on some recent work which
was done in summer last year and we
tried to improve that so our
paper takes the
previous work to next level where we
applied a different way to generate weak
labels we also benchmarked our work with
the google cloud nlp api so we can
confidently say that this has some value
rather than for an enterprise it's
always a question whether we should
build our own or use a third-party api
and using the paper using the work we
were able to justify why it makes sense
that of course we can deliver as good of
model but also there are a few unique
features that we can provide we want get
with the google cloud nlp api and we
also perform some domain specific
analysis on it so this is um about paper
and
i'll quickly summarize
uh
about my overall experience for a
professional certificate so i have uh i
did three courses uh
and these are uh three courses again
like
there are lots of reason why i did it
but
kobe is also one of that reason uh this
was like summer 2020 during kobe nothing
else to do
and i think this was the best use of
time that i could have done
and for natural language processing
course for me key learning i was already
working on lots of computer reasons uh
stuff and i was working on audio so if
you are familiar with the audio audio
requires uh takes concept from
computer visa and it takes concept from
nlp but i
have not worked enough on nlp so this
was like good stage for me to take it to
next level so i learned about rnn base
model here transformer and attention and
attention is a really
key concept
or one of the best concepts that has
come out in recent years with this i was
able to apply a tension in one of my
models and was able to improve it
and we were able to train state of the
art model for voice biometrics
then
uh
other course i did was in the winter
that was ai principle and technics as
steve manson this course takes uh
challenges you to a very next level
where you
you don't use any library like pytorch
or anything else you have to write code
originally and if you really want to
challenge yourself both theoretically
and practically this is a really good
course for that and then the last one is
natural language understanding which is
uh
as i mentioned most of the detail but
for me key learning there was
using the bird family of models so
and i had a very good
time doing this course and i feel that
the course is completely worth it so
yeah this has been my experience
if you have any question please let me
know
um yeah
thanks
awesome thank you so much navdeep for
your your summary of your project as
well as your experience in the course
and the program um just a reminder for
anybody who has questions
about um his project or his program
experience uh feel free to put them in
the q a
um
and we'll take one right here that i see
i think why don't we take one right here
that we see before we move on to to
annika so
uh question for nafta what's the end
goal to get nlp algorithms to understand
customer sentiment what would an
enterprise do differently based on
findings so why don't we take one
question and then uh we'll move on to
annika and say future questions for the
end but yeah you got that question
hi what's the point of the questions
so
i can tell as much i can't
but i'll give you some idea the way we
measure uh whether customer was happy
with uh uh any
interaction any services we use a matrix
called nps i don't know whether you're
familiar with it it's called net
promoter score and you can read about it
how this thing work
so the key idea
and again this is not
described in paper but
it is we want to correlate between
sentiment and a sentiment and nps
so
if a positive sign sentiment relates to
positive nps uh
then
we can find out the conversation where
we have the positive nps and then can
train agents to have a more conversation
like that so that is one of the use
cases
uh
but
yeah i think sentiment is a good clue to
improve a user experience
so that is where uh we are looking to
have some improvement
great thanks snapdeep so some i see some
other folks asking questions as well i
think we'll um
save some of those until after annika
presents as well and sort of do a big
block of time for q a
uh but up next uh thanks navdeep uh
annika uh who has stayed up
well not stayed up but skip dinner i
suppose in europe to join us today uh
feel free to um
uh open up your camera and your mic uh
for your
for your slides as well and annika will
also be sharing her 224u project and she
also completed three classes
and the whole ai professional
certificate so annika go ahead if you
can hear us
yes i can hear
you i assume you can hear me as well you
know and you can also see me okay
so uh
thanks for having me and don't mind
about my dinner i always eat late i'm
like more like that midnight dinner type
of person so
no problem there um
yeah
i will um skip this a little bit i will
first start with introducing who i am
because i i
think i might be or i had the feeling
during taking the course that i was
a little bit of an exotic figure as
or particularly considering my cohort so
um it might be interesting for you to
get to know me a little bit better
before learning about my project
then i will present my show my project
quite briefly and in the end i will um
have it like the other way around as an
update in the end i will conclude with a
certain
tips i would give to people particularly
for people who
come from a similar background as i do
and um
recount a bit of some obstacles um i
encountered um during my way on to the
ii certified
certificate and some
yeah some detours i unnecessarily took
and i could have prevented if i planned
things differently um from the beginning
so
um
to start with who i am
i am i think one of the few people who
have taken this um ii program
who
um who does not have a background in
computer science or engineering or any
hard science at all
i my background is completely from the
social sciences i have an um
ma in communication studies with a minor
in psychology and and um
german literary studies and um i am on
my way to my doctorate so my phd studies
in media psychology so not an engineer
not a computer scientist a mathematician
or anything like that
but i do have um
quite a bit of background in programming
because um
my work in my my research primarily
focuses on quantitative projects so i
came in touch with spss
programming quite early
back in at university and for my own
projects
incorporated matlab quite quite early on
and then switched to um r
but to be honest i didn't have that
really really much background in python
programming
just a little bit um i tended um to
switch to python only every time when i
wanted to do something with non-ascii
characters data sets containing nothing
as key character characters because that
can be a pain in the ass when you do
this in in r but i'm not a professional
or wasn't a professional when it comes
to python programming
um also i'm not from the industry i come
from the public sector i am a research
assistant currently at the german police
university which is sounds sounds funny
maybe but it's actually a thing
in germany um
it started several years ago that
everyone who wants to enter police
leadership level will have to have a
master's degree or obtain a master's
degree from the german police university
so what i do is that i teach law
enforcement officers who want to be
leading law enforcement officers
and i do research in the field of online
radicalization
and particularly their jihadi and
right-wing online radicalization so i
sort of
already came into this project with a
strong interest in fields like an nlp to
handle big data especially social media
data
um
about my project
i ended up doing something
completely different from my or not
completely but quite different from from
what i originally wanted to do
um
my primary goal um which with which i
started was to do something um yeah so
to have sort of a little bit of um
synergy effects for my phd project so i
my my goal was to have a publication by
the end of this course which can be a
part of my
phd and so i wanted to do something
quite fancy had a strong
really um
developed theoretical background where i
wanted to to
um
to treat um
social media data for um
and measure some sort of emotional
alignment in different or between
different um extremist communities on
the web
however this didn't quite turn out
um nafty already told you that there's
three parts to to this um course project
and the first one is the literature
review
i did this literature review almost
entirely on this and that i wanted to
that but then found out or had to find
out um the hard way that it's
maybe not ideal to to start from a
theoretical model or only from
only with with a really cool um
hypothesis um in mind and neglect the
fact of which data are already out there
or not and i had to learn that
there wasn't really much data which
would be my i would um
match my my hypothesis and i would have
to do a lot of data cleaning or
um gathering data myself and this
course is certainly not the place for
this because you simply do not have the
time for this
so i ended up doing something which i
found at first um much smaller than i
originally intended
but during my literature review um
i um reviewed quite a few um
papers suggesting um systems for emotion
classification
and naftive already mentioned things
like the um
really powerful transformer-based
language modeling
techniques and and um
um
vector space models and and um wedding
beddings that became popular recently
and there were quite a few on papers
making really strong points about really
nice effect classification systems
however quite in the end when i was
always almost done with my um literature
review i came across a paper which is
also which i found funny also a paper
that came from
a former cohort of the um this project
and this program
not the the um
um professional program but the so to
speak real stanford um program and
they discussed that all those
fancy classification systems um have a
bit of
a bias when it comes to
non-general language contexts because we
don't express emotions or sentiment
always in the same manner but the way we
express emotions or sentiments
is at least partially a bit dependent on
the context we're in and the peers
you're communicating with the the sub
community you're communicating in
so these um
models uh
try to to be a little bit um
unprecise or misclassify a lot of
material when you are in really um
exceptional context and i would argue
that things like or context where
extremists are gathering on the internet
for instance this is a non-general
context and a way where emotions might
not be expressed as they would be
um well in general
so
what is needed there is
not only a nice algorithm but also um
for feature selection dictionaries that
portray or i so speak domain specific to
certain contexts but
you can of course not generate such a
dictionary for every context that's
interesting for you and do this manually
by hand because then again you would
only have the dictionaries for once for
the context that somebody has already
done this before
so we you would also
be on the look for
for algorithms that might generate such
dictionaries more or less automatically
for you
and
there are some
label propagation algorithms which have
been quite successfully
successful in the last years and which i
found quite promising
unfortunately those labor provocation
algorithms so far
have not never been applied to emotion
analysis or emotion
label on generation emotion dictionary
generation but rather to
sentiment polarity generation so only
differentiating whether um something is
positive neutral or negative
and one of the um
most cited or i think one of the most
famous um sentiment propagation
algorithms is the scent prop framework
developed by hamilton and colleagues and
so what i wanted to do in this
course is something
i think quite quite simple or like
really really targeted and really
focused um
um on this specific question is try to
make um the scent prop algorithm work
not only for sentiment detection but
also adapt this to the um
to the domain of emotion or effect
induction so those were my two
hypothesis the first one is that because
the um psychometric properties of
emotions and sentiment are quite similar
i would argue that the sentiment sent
prop algorithm can be leveraged to
induce the main specific emotion lexica
and also in turn then be used to
describe um
uh variations in in the expression of
different emotions in diverse um radical
communities or different communities on
reddit
and the second hypothesis
um which is a little bit more more
technical one um the centroid algorithm
algorithm itself is from 2000 um stems
from 2016
and in the field of nlp this is almost
like i have the feeling like like from
the last century or something because um
this was um before
those um
[Music]
uh
transformer-based um embeddings became
popular like
roberta or bird or things like this and
so
the algorithm is working with already
working with embeddings but not with the
transformer based embeddings yet so my
second hypothesis would be that the
performance of this algorithm might be
boosted or could be boosted even further
by implementing or incorporating
vector transformer-based virtual
referentiations
in my case particularly bird
however um i do not know who
of you is already familiar with this
these transformer based models um they
have a little bit of the downside that
[Music]
transformer based
word representations come in quite a
different format than the usual
lookup table formatted word
representations
like models like for instance glove over
to veg
so um because they are dynamic
representations which take the context
into consideration and the others are
static representations
so um you can't just interchange one
model against the other in your
algorithm
but you would have to turn those
[Music]
transformer-based
word representations into static word
representations first and this is
something which was quite new there was
one paper i think i have the reference
on the next slide or
the one after that
um
that proposes a method for turning these
dynamic context-based word
representations
back into static ones and if you do this
you can easily apply them or integrate
them in the same
central algorithm so that was basically
all i did was taking
two already existing approaches merging
them and applying them to my own
hypothesis regarding
emotion detection
and
i needed quite a lot of resources um for
this project um which i will point this
out um later on
can be uh
something um
yeah probably dangerous um so make sure
not to be needy of too many different
resources because
gathering resourcing resources aligning
them cleaning them
might be much more work than you expect
them
to be the first set of resources which i
needed were so-called seed words
from which the scent prop algorithm
progresses i will explain this on the
next slide and um
hamilton already came up with a seed
words for
sentiments i don't know if you can read
them there i i guess a little bit um
a little bit small here and he um
for each sentiment a positive um
negative he started off with ten seat
words one representing the positive and
one uh the other ten the negative
um scale
and i did the same by simply choosing by
help
with the help of the webster dictionary
good representations of the positive
scales of
certain emotions in my case i chose
contempt disgust and anger which has a
bit to do with my theoretical background
in the social science or in the field of
radicalization research there is a model
which is called the so-called acondi
model which states that
these courses on the web tend to become
particularly violent when you have anger
discussed and content
combined so
i investigated those three particular
emotions or effects
and those words were chosen by myself
then i needed to gather whirling
beddings and therefore i took the um
already static so to speak standard um
wording bettings like glove twitter
train glove trained on twitter
were to back and then also applied um
the
static um or turning um dynamic
representations into static
representations algorithm
um proposed by bomanzani and colleagues
um to the bird represent to the bird
model
those were my my
uh three types of
wedding beddings i chose
then i gathered um reddit data
and um
therefore i i used the push shift
rp
which is a quite straightforward method
to get those data so i could um within
several
minutes or hours
really crawl a huge date a reddit data
set which didn't need much more cleaning
um afterwards anymore and then finally
um which is also will be clearer on the
next slide i needed so-called target
category dictionaries uh
against which i could test um the
performance of the algorithm those were
dictionaries that already um
listed words associated with either um
sentiment polarity or certain effects so
i could test how well
or
have a measure how well the algorithm
actually works by comparing the
dictionary that the algorithm produced
against the dictionaries which have
already been
so to be gratified by other people or by
the past um
scientific community for those contacts
and so
this is um
the scheme or the overall scheme of the
um
i built which partly
partially was done within the course
project
but a little bit of this what is here in
the in the workflow charge is still
pending is something i would want to do
um
or i'm doing now because i
would want to have this done before i
upload or publish the paper
but um in the end i was running out of
time so it was
still a big of an endeavor to to do
everything or accomplish everything i
would like to have done um
and but what i i did or what the the
algorithm basically is supposed to do
is that it starts off with the selection
of
wood embedding spaces um either the
static ones like um
virtuevec or glove or
the more fancy newer supposedly better
word embedding spaces like bird which
are then turned into static
representation by the manzani algorithm
and what the senp algorithm and its care
function core functionality does is that
it takes those embedding spaces and
applies a k-near nearest neighbor
modeling um to it so that it creates
sort of like
a map
um
or
a landscape
of those those words and um
um
sorts them or opposes them um
next to each other or far away from each
other according to to the similarity of
context in which they appear
and so you you can sort of have like a
graph representation of your entire
vocabulary
and then in the next step and this is
why we needed the seed words
we are starting random works in this
embedding space from the chosen seed
works that you know or you said
are either representing the positive or
the negative scale of an emotion
and then you apply several um
random walks across the um um
[Music]
this um
graph representation
and depending on how often or if at all
um
one word hits or
crosses another word um
in this vocabulary
uh starting off from those seed words
you can say that it's either associated
with this part or the other other poll
of the emotion
and you do this repeatedly several times
and by this you can
sort of create
your dictionary lists which you can then
use to to
[Music]
describe your
models later on
and which i would like to do
further on is um
to also um
[Music]
test this against um
other algorithms for immersion
classification um at the sentence level
but i was not there yet but what i
could accomplish in the during the
course of this this
course project
is test
this model if it works at all for
emotions
and if it works better when you um
incorporate um transformer based
language models
and what you can see is that it's
you have a little bit of mixed results i
don't know if you can read this table
but um what i found out is then when you
are
having standard english domains
you are still better off
implementing the the systems that were
proposed in the original algorithm so
not relying on on
um
on
birch
as your embedding space but when you
want to target emotions particularly in
online media like like twitter or edit
then you actually have this um
hypothesized boost in performance when
you use um
based vector space models
and this is just um so to to
put this in context a little bit again
if you use those um
emotion
[Music]
word lists that you can induce with this
procedure you can indeed find if you
compare your web communities across
these
that you find certain similarities that
for instance all the
the radical communities like the red
pill community where we have the insults
um discussing
highly
misogynist topics for and and the far
right people they all find it for um
have a similar way of expressing
expressing um
different emotions when you um applied
this scent prop algorithm first so it's
actually um
a nice way for me as a social scientist
to find out um something
actually on on how emotion is expressed
so it's not only a a technical issue um
for me as a social scientist of course i
don't know
i'm not only interested if a bird model
is better than than glove or something
but i really want to know what it's good
for in the end how can i describe a
social phenomena with this and this is
really something pretty useful describe
social phenomena because it really helps
me
identify or cluster particularly radical
um communities on the web
um
yeah that's what i did one more one more
minute if you have
and then we'll leave we want to make
sure we have some type of questions so
we'll go for one more
minute yeah i will speed that up um just
what it's still left to do is i would
like to um
test this
also with another um
what embedding space the birch tweed
which is particularly um might be even
better because it's tailored towards
some
online materials not general language
but online
discourses
then i would like to um
test this way of of classifying or
finding emotions in
these courses also on the the sentence
level because um and test this against
other algorithms the the baseline
algorithms
which are proposed at the moment by the
um
goal emotion data set which is i think
the benchmark emotion data set to test
emotion classification and then of
course i would like to tidy up my my
code i think which is something that
everyone always does because i on the
last slide i put a link to my um
also my github repository so if you're
ever having imposter syndrome or
something take a look at this this is
how actual messy code looks like at the
end of such a project
so yes and i think we don't have much
time for this anymore so i leave this to
to maybe reading
those are the the tips i would have um
for the um for mastering this program
especially when you're social scientist
and maybe used to work
quite differently normally
but yeah maybe we will touch upon
several of these aspects in this
discussion now
awesome thank you so much for sharing a
super fascinating topic and background
also it's great to that you're able to
share sort of where you came from for
the program um from here in the last 10
minutes we'll talk a little bit about
the program and we have some questions
here that i'll try to cover as we talk
about it very briefly but i'll also ask
navdeep uh and annika to chime in with
any thoughts that they have as well
um on some of these questions and we can
share annika's paper and github profile
as she mentioned
for folks who are still interested
in browsing that so
um
as mentioned um let me advance these
slides and we can share that out
this was just one project
or one one assignment from all of these
courses um i believe navdeep took two to
the nlp class the nlu class and i forgot
what his third was it was his 229 um
all of these courses are based off of
graduate material at stanford so you
actually do use
the uh regular graduate classroom
lectures so for those of you we get a
lot of questions about the machine
learning class that andrew ing teaches
versus the coursera course um the
graduate the courses that we have in the
professional program go to much more
additional levels of depth and breadth
uh from the course on on coursera which
is a great uh starter and introduction
to some of these things
um a question that we got several times
in the chat was whether or not it's
recommended to take two classes at once
um
in general we recommend that it's not
because we find that a lot of the
classes take eight hours to 15 hours a
week and sometimes people spend more
depending on what they're doing on the
project or what their background in
python is so uh navdeep or annika i'm
not sure if you want to chime in
with thoughts the time command also
varies by class some are more math heavy
some are more programming heavy and to
be honest it actually depends on what
your background is and your your comfort
with both but um navdeep do you want to
share anything from your experience or
annika from your experience and or in
your opinion in general our guidance is
not to do two at once but i'm curious if
you all have any thoughts
sure i think i if you are a working
professional one course is more than
enough you will find
even though yeah i mean i made this xcs2
for you as my work other i don't think i
would have been able to finish it if it
was not my work project
it's a lots of work
uh again it depends on you do you just
want to clear those assignments get and
pass it
or you want to learn uh all the concepts
like go deeper into it and i think that
is where one course at a time is you'll
find that it is more than enough it will
take your whole week
um
if you are really interested in knowing
the concept rather than just passing the
course so
i would recommend one at a time
yeah and i don't know if you have
anything to add or if you did them one
by one but um in general the guidance is
to to take one yeah for me definitely
also one of the time if i may go back in
the slides here there's something i
might recommend
for someone who has like me also a plain
social science background i started with
the i think moth heaviest of all courses
with the two to nine one
which was quite challenging for me and i
was quite glad that there was this
example test set on the on the page
before the enrollment
so i even started to to set back for
three entire months before enrolling
into this course
and redid um calculus and
linear algebra on on khan academy
because otherwise i would not definitely
would not have passed this course
because my my
um high school math is still so many
years back and um
yeah
so that was really challenging so um
yeah so that leads to an additional
question that we got a couple times in
here which is about prerequisites um we
do
you know it is recommended you have a
strong math background in calculus
linear algebra but you can also you know
we don't require that you go take a
formal class um there's free resources
on khan academy there's also a great
specialization uh i think it's called
math for machine learning that's on
coursera offered by um i think
ucl in london that many folks we see do
before they take the course
ultimately because this is a
professional program our admissions are
fairly open we ask you to self-report
you know your your math background and
your statistics background and your
python background but there's no
entrance exam
uh or anything like that
um and then for the assignments another
question that i see here is what
language are the assignments in um the
assignments are in python
and um
most of the courses actually have
assignments in just raw python files
which i think navdeep mentioned um you
know you'll you'll be working to build
things from scratch and then two of the
classes including 224u which we're
talking about today
um uh uh
use jupyter notebooks but most of the
classes actually use uh raw python files
and um the environment looks like this
where you'll have an assignment you'll
submit it to our auto grader and it'll
provide you with feedback and and
results
um throughout the course there's also
support from course facilitators who uh
you can go to with your questions uh for
the course and we have a slack community
where you can ask questions about
assignments as well as schedule office
hours um with a dedicated
point of contact um
one question that i see here in the chat
from a couple people that that annika
and navdeep can both speak to is
potentially sort of like kind of what's
the overlap or what's the perspective of
two two four u versus two to four n
um one person asked about taking them at
the same time which we've covered i
think but can you talk a little bit
about you know i have my view but your
experience in in uh and i know navdeep
definitely took both annika i'm not sure
if you took both but navdeep can you can
you if you did can you talk a little bit
about
the areas of overlap the areas of
difference and kind of like how the two
elements of t24n and t24u actually may
fit together for somebody who's
interested in diving into that whole
universe
yeah of course uh
so both are very different courses uh
the first one two to four and you learn
from the scratch about evaluate
evolution of natural language
processing techniques so
some of the concepts even goes back like
what was there in 90s to up to a point
rnn and it comes up to a stage where you
get introduced to concept of attention
and transformer but there is
uh no practical application there for
assignment and
nlu picks up where i think uh
nlp left which was like you can
literally you will from first assignment
itself you will be applying some of
those transformer based model
for
word embedding and things like that so
from learning perspective and
application perspective i think it's a
good journey
um
now again like there are lots of things
right
as steve also highlighted what is your
background how much you already know if
you already know how python works if you
are familiar with like uh
sequential models rnn models
and you just want to learn the new
concept so xcs224u i think has
newer concepts but again i think
they keep on updating so like i'm not
sure if has there been any update for
xcs224 and
uh i would recommend both in a sequence
but it depends on like what you are
trying to achieve do you have a timeline
issue
um do you have something
in mind you want to work on immediately
then if you just want to grab
uh understanding of the latest go for
xcs224u
but only if you already understand lots
of ml concept otherwise start with csv
beforehand
yeah
monica was i'm not sure if you have
anything to add if that was experience
as well we do see that about 60 to 70
percent of people in 224 eu
took 224n first so it's not a hard
requirement of ours but we actually see
more than half of people do that
yes i i did the same
also um i i think uh i would not
change the order of my courses i really
started with this moth heavy um
somewhat nasty two to nine
and from then proceeded with two to four
n which is like nafti said really about
the basic concepts and it's nice because
then you have like the first way of
applying the math you learned in two to
nine
and and then two to um for you is like
really hands-on you're like thrown more
or less thrown into the open water and
you can do whatever you like which gives
you a lot of freedom
but also um
can be a bit
intimidating or this is um
something i might
probably want to add to the coding
language question you already mentioned
that we are
the bake offs and everything you do in
before you start with your project in
229u is primarily based on jupiter
notebooks which are nice but that was
kind of one of the obstacles i
encountered i wanted to all go on for my
course project also with jupiter
notebooks and they are really not ideal
for debugging and really developing a
project they are nice when you're using
frameworks but not when you're working
something from stretch and you will be
spending 90 percent of your time
debugging code
and and so i started to set up my ida
ide ways too late in the project
and um this is something i would give as
a really strong recommendation before
you start with chat um
two to nine you
and you
do not have much background in python
only ever had like two or three jupiter
notebooks or so get yourself familiar
with with an ide and start a little bit
of debugging and get to know debugging
beforehand and not
on the course this won't work or will
make time management really challenging
otherwise
good awesome
um well we have reached the top of the
hour we apologize for not being able to
get to all of the questions but if you
do have further questions i see some
questions about logistics and about the
course availability and those types of
things uh you should feel free to get in
touch with our team
um uh with those questions uh around
course availability and ordering and
those types of things um and the last
thing i wanted to share is we do have a
few profiles uh you just heard from
annika and navdeep about their journey
and their learnings we have a couple of
other profiles uh posted on our website
as well about how different people have
used this program and used these courses
to
further their interests and their
learning and their career and so we
encourage you to check those out um
uh as well so with that i just want to
again thank navdeep and annika for
joining us for sharing their projects
for talking a little bit um about their
experience in the program these these
projects are always so interesting we
could talk for hours about them and
there's tons of ques people always have
tons of questions so they're always
fascinating to hear
uh we want to thank you both uh for your
time and for sharing and uh for
everybody who joined this as well and so
this webinar will be shared out um with
everyone and as i mentioned if we do
have questions that we were not able to
address uh you should feel free to get
in touch with our team so thank you so
much annika enjoy your dinner thank you
so much navdeep i appreciate you sharing
your project and uh thank you everybody
for joining
you